c'est un pays qui compte
particulièrement sur l'aide de l'onu
pour sortir du chaos après neuf ans de
guerre et de divisions politiques la
libye semble avoir retrouvé un semblant
de stabilité malgré un état faible et de
multiples confrontations armées face aux
nations unies le premier ministre libyen
va à nouveau sollicité le soutien de
l'organisation au gouvernement d'union
nationale le g n a qu il dirige depuis
décembre 2015
fayez al saad possède à son crédit
quelques réussites
il est notamment parvenu à obtenir le
ralliement des autorités économiques et
politiques de la capitale tripoli
il peut aussi se targuer d'avoir
notamment renforcer l'armée qui a obtenu
des victoires contre le groupe etat
islamique et les forces du maréchal
haftar l'autre homme fort du pays qui
contrôlent l'est du territoire
mais sa volonté de rassembler n'a pas
permis de surmonter tous les obstacles
fayez al sa rage n'a ainsi pas réussi à
convaincre le parlement exilé dans l'est
du pays à tobrouk est qui soutient son
grand rival la personnalité d'elle sa
rage ne fait également pas consensus au
sein de plusieurs pays arabes qui ont
choisi de soutenir le maréchal haftar
dans ce contexte et pour permettre au
pouvoir libyen de trouver un nouveau
souffle
vas y et al sa rage a fait part de son
intention de démissionner fin octobre
mais à des menaces avant par la neige
mais j'annonce attouchements désir
sincère de remettre mes fonctions à la
prochaine administration au plus tard à
la fin du mois d'octobre prochain
j'espère que le comité de négociation
aura alors achevé ses travaux et choisi
un homme au conseil présidentiel
moi je ne sais bien si
gelli malgré le départ annoncé de celui
qu'elle soutient l'onu a déjà pris des
initiatives pour poursuivre la lente
reconstruction libyenne
la mission des nations unies dans le
pays a été prolongée sur le plan
politique
l'onu est également en train de
reprendre la main notamment sur les
négociations des rivaux libyens ont
repris des pourparlers en suisse et à
bouznika au maroc pour trouver une
solution politique à leur différend mais
en attendant une issue diplomatique
la colère de la population se fait
entendre
les manifestations se multiplient dans
l'est et à l'ouest contre l'élite
politique et la détérioration des
conditions de vie notamment les longues
coupures d'électricité
le chemin de la reconstruction s'annonce
donc toujours complexe en libye les deux
camps rivaux ont pourtant affiché leur
bonne volonté lors de leur dernière
rencontre ils ont convenu d'organiser
des élections présidentielle et
parlementaires d'ici à 18 mois
en attendant un gouvernement d'unité
représentatifs devrait être mise en
place